there are many different video essays
examining ex machina but there's one
simple aspect of the film that intrigues
me that I haven't seen anyone else talk
about while discussing the film's ending
with people two distinct interpretations
are apparent some view Ava as a villain
others as a victim do you know what the
Turing test is it's when a human
interacts with a computer and if the
human doesn't know they're interacting
with a computer the test is passed
I think ex machina allows the viewer to
participate in a type of Turing test the
association between Caleb as the human
component you're going to be the human
component the Turing test and the viewer
as a human component in the test is
reinforced visually by portraying Caleb
as always viewing Ava through a screen
or glass eye but this test is a little
different from a regular Turing test
it's just in the Turing test the machine
should be hidden from the examiner
and you can see that I'm a machine like
Caleb in the film you already know Ava
is an AI no no we're way past that
if I hit able from you so you just heard
her voice she would pass for human the
real test is to show you that she's a
robot and then see if you still feel she
has consciousness like an AI in real
life in a story an AI can pass or fail a
viewers test so how do we know if Ava
has passed the test
Antoninus how do you feel about nothing
analytical just how do you feel
Caleb in ex machina and the audiences of
stories with a I aren't testing for
intelligence they're testing for
Humanity they're testing how they feel
about the character and it's not that
hard for a filmmaker to get a robot to
pass the test just give it some eyebrows
so it can show expression make it a
little vulnerable what does this action
signify give it some curiosity as you
entered when you look at the other human
what does it mean and have it experience
emotions with a few of these things the
audience will likely accept that the AI
has a sort of humanity in a broader
sense it's this process that allows an
audience to easily accept that a trash
robot has a capacity for love for many
films the filmmakers have a desired
outcome for their Turing test in mind
I'd hope you would come to think of me
as your friend
but in ex machina the question is left
hanging for the audience writer and
director Alex Garland wrote the story so
you could choose the protagonist but I
don't think it's much of a choice your
perspective on who the protagonist is
and your interpretation of the ending is
largely influenced by whether she passes
or fails the test for you
if Ava begins to provoke your empathy
and you desire for her to be given the
same rights and respect a human should
be she's passed
are you attracted to me what are you
attracted to me it gives me indications
that you are
Caleb's conviction that Ava deserves
freedom is the ultimate indication that
she's passed the test for him her AI is
beyond doubt if she passes the test you
will likely see her escape as justified
do you think I might be switched off
because I don't function as far as I
supposed to know intelligent being with
humanity deserves imprisonment and death
without cause but if you see her as
merely a manipulative robot and you
don't buy into her humanity she's a
dangerous monster who figured out a way
to free herself an AI failing the users
test doesn't indicate a lack of
intelligence it indicates a lack of
perceived humanity and much of our fears
surrounding AI don't involve them being
smart it involves them being inhuman our
perspective on AI and stories
illustrates a trap we sometimes fall
into in how we think about them and it
also makes clear the problems with
actual Turing tests as a way to test for
consciousness why do we assume that
something that could pass is necessarily
conscious or the bigger question for me
why do we often assume that anything
that would be conscious would appear
human enough to pass the test
because the only consciousnesses that
were aware of our human ones we often
assume that anything that appears
conscious has a bit of humanity but even
if something appears to display humanity
you're still left with the question is
it real or is it a trick does Ava
actually like you or not although now
that I think about it there is a third
action not whether she does it does not
have the capacity to like you whether
she's pretending to like you
in ex machina this is the flaw and
thinking that gets killed killed the
film purposefully avoids
answering these questions leaving it to
you to decide does Ava pass
[Music]
thank you to Squarespace for helping
make this video possible Squarespace is
a simple yet powerful platform for
building websites that look amazing
everything you need to build the website
is right there you don't have to install
plug-ins or find hosting or any of that
stuff
whether you're a youtuber filmmaker
freelancer or just have any kind of
creative or business endeavor
Squarespace is a great way to build a
website that showcases your creations
we don't have sentient a is yet to build
us websites but Squarespace is probably
the next best thing I've been using it
for years and I actually kind of find it
a little fun to build and create a
website using their platform you can
start your free trial today at
squarespace.com slash Thomas flight or
use code
Thomas flight to get 10% off your first
purchase or you can click on the link in
the description at squarespace.com slash
thomas flight to get started building
your website today thank you to
Squarespace thank you to you for
watching and thank you to my patrons for
their support if you want to learn more
about how you can support my content go
to patreon.com/scishow